este es un ejercicio de lacan academy
para graficar funciones exponenciales
básicas y en esencia nos piden graficar
la siguiente función exponencial y aquí
nos dan la función exponencial dice hdx
igual a un medio por un quinto elevado a
la equis verdad entonces la idea de este
ejercicio es que nosotros podemos mover
estos dos puntos verdad donde nosotros
queramos y también puedan podemos mover
la acin total de esta función verdad
entonces por ejemplo puede ser que sea
una cinta digamos para x muy grandes o
para x digamos para x positivos pero muy
grandes o para x muy grandes pero
negativos verdad entonces vamos a tratar
de resolver este problema de hecho la
función ya está dada en su forma digamos
estándar verdad el punto inicial sería
un medio y nuestra razón común es un
quinto ok entonces pensemos qué es lo
que pasa cuando tenemos x igual
a 0 movámonos con x igual a cero y con x
igual a cero un quinto a la equis sería
uno que si después lo multiplicamos por
un medio nos da un medio o lo que es lo
mismo 0.5 que pasaría ahora si por
ejemplo x fuera no sé x fuera digamos
menos uno menos uno si x fuera menos uno
un quinto a la menos uno sería cinco
verdad es justo el recíproco o el
inverso multiplicativo entonces cuando x
vale menos uno un quinto a la menos uno
es 5 por un medio sería cinco medios
verdad cinco medios son 3.5
3.5
no es cierto son 2.5 verdad 5 entre 2
son 2.5 y ahora pensemos que es lo que
puede ocurrir con nuestra asín total y
lo que ocurre aquí es que un quinto
digamos elevado al cuadrado sería 1
entre 25 un quinto elevado al cubo sería
1 entre 125 entonces podemos ver que
este número a medida que x se va
haciendo cada vez más grande se va
apareciendo más a 0 verdad y como
multiplica una con una constante en
realidad esto se va viendo de esta forma
cuando x es muy grande se va apareciendo
a 0
veamos si es cierto todo esto es
correcto vamos a hacer otro ejercicio
muy bien tenemos el mismo ejercicio solo
que ahora tenemos gdx igual a menos 12
por 4 elevado a la equis entonces
pensemos ahora que es lo que ocurre
cuando x es igual a 0 x igual a cero
tendremos 4 a la 0 que es 1 que
multiplica menos 12 entonces nuestro
primer punto
- 12 menos 12 muy bien ahora qué pasa
cuando digamos vamos a poner x igual a
menos uno cuando x es igual a menos 14 a
la menos 1 es un cuarto y un cuarto por
menos 12 sería menos 3 verdad tendríamos
menos 3 y ahora como podríamos
determinar la asiento está aquí podemos
ver que en efecto la función se
aproximará a nuestra sin tota cuando x
tiende a menos infinito y es que
pensemos 4 a la menos 1 es un cuarto 4 a
la menos 2 es un dieciseisavo 4 a la
menos 3 sería el 1 entre 64 verdad
entonces podemos ver que 4 a la equis se
va apareciendo
digamos cada vez más a 0 cuando x se va
haciendo más y más y más negativo
entonces esta cinta será 0 y podemos ver
que entonces está bien dibujada así que
veamos si estamos en lo correcto
estábamos en lo correcto